ELECTION WORKS.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THEY ARE
DOING.
SORRY.
IT'S TRUE.
STEPHEN MILLER IS FULLY AWARE OF
THIS.
THAT'S WHY THEY HATE HIM.
THE FORMER SENIOR ADVISER OF THE
WHITE HOUSE AND JOINS US
TONIGHT.
STEPHEN MILLER, THINK SO MUCH
FOR COMING ON.
I THINK FOR NORMAL PEOPLE, THEY
TEND TO BE VERY LITERAL.
SO COVID IS A REAL DISEASE THAT
KILLS A LOT OF PEOPLE AND
EVERYONE WANTS TO BE SAFE.
OKAY, WE WILL HEAR YOU OUT.
REFUGEES, AMERICANS, THEY ARE
BIGHEARTED AND WANT TO HELP
PEOPLE THAT HELPED US.
THEY WANT TO HELP IN GENERAL.
YOU KNOW, THEY WANT TO DO THE
RIGHT THING.
I DON'T THINK A LOT OF NORMAL
AMERICANS, BOTH PARTIES SEE THAT
THERE IS A POLITICAL MOTIVE
BEHIND THESE POLICIES, BUT THERE
CLEARLY IS.
>> WELL, WHAT WE ARE WITNESSING
RIGHT NOW, TUCKER, IS THE
GREATEST BAIT AND SWITCH OF ALL
TIME.
HE JOE BIDEN CALLOUSLY PLAYED ON
AMERICA'S SYMPATHIES FOR A SMALL
CORE OF AFGHANS WHO WORKED
CLOSELY IN DIFFICULT CONDITIONS
WITH AMERICAN TROOPS, LEFT ALL
OF THOSE PEOPLE NEARLY IN
AFGHANISTAN, AND THEN IN THEIR
STEAD BROUGHT OVER 100,000
RANDOMLY SELECTED AFGHAN
NATIONALS, AND HE IS NOT BRINGIG
THEM TO THE UNITED STATES
THROUGH ANY LAWFUL PROCESS OR
ANY LAWFUL VETTING CHAINS.
AND MY SOURCES INSIDE THE
GOVERNMENT ARE VERY CLEAR THAT
MOST OF THESE INDIVIDUALS, WHEN
YOU RUN A BACKGROUND CHECK, IT
COMES UP BLANK.
THEY ARE GHOSTS.
NOBODY KNOWS WHO THEY ARE.
OF COURSE IF THEY WORK FOR THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT, WHEN YOU CHECK
THEIR FINGERPRINTS, THEY WOULD
COME UP RIGHT AWAY.
BUT THERE ARE NO MATCHES.
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T WORK FOR THE
GOVERNMENT AND NOBODY KNOWS WHO
THEY ARE.
BUT IT GETS WORSE, I HAVE ALSO
BEEN INFORMED VERY CREDIBLY THAT
THIS IS THE BEGINNING, NOT THE
END OF THE REFUGEE SETTLEMENT
OPERATION.
AS WE SPEAK, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS MAKING
PREPARATIONS THROUGH ITS FOREIGN
CONSULATES AND MISSIONS TO
ACCEPT IN AN OPEN-ENDED,
UNENDING WAY AFGHAN NATIONALS
WHO LEAVE THE COUNTRY AND APPLY
AT ANY U.S. MISSION AROUND THE
GLOBE.
MOST OF THAT WILL BE HAPPENING
IN PAKISTAN.
AGAIN, THEY WILL BYPASS LOCAL
VISA CHANNELS AND IF NECESSARY,
ABUSE AND IN FACT VIOLATE A LAW
KNOWN AS PAROLE THAT IS MEANT
FOR CASE-BY-CASE CIRCUMSTANCES
AND BRING THOSE INDIVIDUALS INTO
COUNTRY WITH NO REAL VETTING AND
NO REAL KNOWLEDGE OF WHO THEY
ARE.
BUT MORE IMPORTANT THAN ALL OF
THIS, TUCKER, IS COMMON SENSE.
IF YOU BRING IN SEVERAL
PROVINCES THAT WORTH OF
INDIVIDUALS FROM AFGHANISTAN,
YOU ARE REPLICATING THE
CONDITIONS IN AFGHANISTAN HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA,
AND ALL OF THE HORRORS THAT
ENTAILS.
>> Tucker: WHICH IS WHY I
THINK MARTHA'S VINEYARD IS A
PERFECT PLACE FOR THEM TO GO.
IT'S BIG ENOUGH FOR 100,000
AFGHAN REFUGEES AND THE PEOPLE
ON THE ISLAND CAN AFFORD TO
HELP.
THEY SAY THEY CARE.
EVERY SINGLE AFGHAN REFUGEES
SHOULD BE MOVED TO MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
>> OPEN THEIR HOME, THERE ARE
CLUBS, THEIR PRIVATE DINNE